[Aplausos]
[Música]
bangladesh es el único país islámico
presidido por una mujer
sheikh hasina y no se trata de un
ejemplo insustancial hablamos del tercer
país más grande del mundo musulmán con
más de 160 millones de habitantes
[Música]
sin embargo este país ha dado a gente
mucho más famosa que su presidenta
efectivamente hablamos de mohamed yunus
premio nobel de la paz y conocido
mundialmente por ser el banquero que
inventó los microcréditos esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que su
país es una de las sociedades menos
bancarizadas del mundo sólo 1 de cada 3
bangladeshíes tiene cuenta en el banco
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís da igual que
bangladesh sea una de las economías que
más rápido ha crecido en los últimos
años da igual que sean el segundo
fabricante de ropa del mundo sólo por
detrás de china da igual que cada vez
haya menos pobres la mayoría de los
ciudadanos de bangladesh todavía guardan
su dinero en un calcetín y os
preguntaréis por qué qué pasa en
bangladesh para que desconfíen de los
bancos y la respuesta está en la
religión
[Música]
según el islam prestar dinero con
intereses es pecado y el 90 de los
bangladesíes son musulmanes pero esperad
un momento porque las cosas han cambiado
desde hace años los países musulmanes
han inventado un sistema que permite
cumplir con los preceptos del islám y a
la vez ahorrar y pedir préstamos exacto
hablamos de la banca islámica un
fenómeno cada vez más importante en
bangladesh sin embargo para el gobierno
de sheikh hasina esto no son buenas
noticias precisamente
banco islam y los banqueros más
vigilados de bangladesh
con este panorama la pregunta es por qué
el gobierno de bangladesh desconfía de
la banca islámica y lo que es más
importante el papel puede desempeñar lo
que está pasando con la banca islámica
en el futuro de bangladesh hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a responder a otra pregunta aún
más urgente
qué es la banca islámica imaginad que
tenemos mil dólares en una cuenta de
ahorros un banco occidental nos ofrece
una rentabilidad del 3% por ejemplo
seguramente muchos os habréis preguntado
alguna vez cómo es posible que el banco
pueda darnos dinero solo por guardarlo
dónde está su beneficio pues bien lo
cierto es que esos mil dólares que hemos
ingresado no se quedan en la caja fuerte
del banco sino que se utilizan para
prestárselo a otros individuos o
empresas esos préstamos se ofrecen con
un tipo de interés con lo que el banco
gana dinero y a nosotros nos da una
parte de esos beneficios
[Música]
este es el esquema básico de nuestro
sistema bancario por supuesto que hay
muchos mecanismos para evitar riesgos
por ejemplo dependiendo del país en el
que estemos los bancos tendrán que
guardar un porcentaje de esos mil
dólares y no podrán prestarle a ese
porcentaje se le llama coeficiente de
caja pues bien según la sharía este
sistema está pervertido porque prestar
con un tipo de interés es pecado de
usura por supuesto que tú puedes guardar
el dinero de tus clientes pero no puedes
prestárselo a nadie y mucho menos con un
tipo de interés
y jerga económica esto significa que la
sharía exige un sistema con coeficiente
de caja del 100% pues bien este es el
funcionamiento de la banca islámica y os
preguntaréis cómo ganan dinero estos
bancos pues principalmente de dos
maneras por un lado cobrando comisiones
por guardar el dinero es más a
diferencia de los bancos occidentales
que nos dan un interés por guardar
nuestros ahorros
los bancos islámicos sólo pueden hacer
algún regalo simbólico a sus clientes lo
que se conoce con el nombre de iván
[Música]
otro negocio que sí pueden hacer los
bancos islámicos es el cobro de
plusvalías por ejemplo imaginad que
compramos una casa con un banco islámico
en este caso es la entidad quien compra
la casa por nosotros y nos la re vende a
un precio un poquito más alto
la llamada mussara k que podemos
devolver en cómodos plazos si por lo que
sea no podemos terminar de pagar la
vivienda el banco la volvería a poner a
la venta y si sacará algún beneficio
nosotros podríamos llevarnos a alguna
parte
pero esperad un momento porque esto no
es todo también prohíbe a los bancos
islámicos invertir en lo que se
consideran actividades impuras como por
ejemplo el tabaco la producción de armas
o la pornografía es más existe toda una
guía de empresas donde está permitido
invertir el llamado down jones islamic
markets con más de 1.400 valores como os
podéis imaginar este tipo de bancos
están arrasando en casi todo el mundo
musulmán pero en bangladesh es una
auténtica locura
la banca islámica está creciendo
rápidamente en bangladesh con una cuota
de mercado de casi el 20% hoy ya existen
8 bancos de este tipo en bangladesh
incluso algunos bancos occidentales como
citibank están empezando a ofrecer
servicios de banca islámica a los
clientes que lo solicitan en un país
donde los sobornos están presentes en
múltiples aspectos de la vida cotidiana
la banca islámica se ha ganado una
reputación de transparencia y buena
praxis si por un aspecto se
caracterizaba hasta ahora el islam y
punk de bangladesh era por permanecer
ajeno al gobierno
de esta forma digamos que si querías
conseguir un crédito tenías que
garantizar cierta solvencia mientras que
en la banca tradicional nada era más
efectivo que tener un padrino en la
administración o dar una propina o
soborno a la persona adecuada pero
esperad un momento porque las cosas no
pintan tan bien para la banca islámica
como parece
banco bueno banco malo la banca islámica
llegó en 1983 a bangladesh de la mano de
fondos saudíes y kuwaitíes que crearon
el islam y ban tuvo un papel vital con
su financiación para convertir a un país
que era principalmente agrícola en una
de las principales fábricas de ropa del
mundo hecho hoy en día el sector textil
supone un 80% de las exportaciones de
bangladesh y el islám iván es el
principal banco del país desde hace años
sin embargo el crecimiento de la banca
islámica en el país está en cuestión
el banco central de bangladesh no dará
nuevas licencias para bancos islámicos e
incluso esos bancos occidentales que
quieren dar servicios de banca islámica
tienen que esperar el banco central de
bangladesh ha decidido no dar más
licencias con el pretexto de que se
necesita una mayor regulación en la
materia mientras tanto el gobierno de
sheikh hasina ha mandado a inspectores a
las oficinas del islám y bank y está
registrando todos sus movimientos
el gobierno de bangladesh inicia un
golpe al banco más grande del país los
miembros de la junta directiva reciben
una visita de la inteligencia militar y
os preguntaréis qué problema tiene el
gobierno de bangladesh con la banca
islámica pues como os podéis imaginar la
respuesta oficial del gobierno de
bangladesh es la lucha contra el
terrorismo como explicaremos en un
próximo vídeo el integrismo islámico es
cada vez más problemático en este país y
no son pocos quienes sospechan que
alguno de estos bancos podría estar
financiando a grupos terroristas
[Música]
sin embargo hay muchas razones que nos
llevan a pensar que en el fondo se trata
de una lucha de poder si algo le gusta a
sheikh hasina es tener las cosas bajo
control
y que el principal banco del país con
todo su poder económico tenga mayores
simpatías por las propuestas del
principal partido de la oposición
ese que engloba a los integrantes del
partido islámico no es algo que hasina
esté dispuesta a tolerar por eso cuando
este mes de enero
hasina intervino el islam y punk terminó
cambiando a su directiva y colocó a
personas más afines
[Música]
desde entonces los préstamos se han
disparado y según el propio banco
central de bangladesh sin atender a los
criterios de riesgo adecuados mientras
tanto los fondos inversores de arabia
saudita y kuwait que crearon el banco
hace 35 años han tomado nota y han
reducido su participación no creen que
su dinero esté ahora seguro pero esperad
un momento porque esta no es la primera
vez que sheikh hasina intenta controlar
el poder financiero en su país
os acordáis de mohamed yunus pues
también está en el punto de mira de
hasina en el año 2006 tras varios
atentados islamistas el ejército dio un
golpe de estado y por no un gobierno
tecnócrata por aquel entonces el nombre
de yunus sonó con bastante fuerza como
opción para presidir el país finalmente
la candidatura a yunus no se llegó a
concretar pero hasina aprendió la
lección cuidado con los banqueros que a
veces les da por meterse en política
[Música]
por eso lo primero que hizo fascina al
tomar el gobierno dos años más tarde fue
encargarse de yunus para empezar le
destituyó de su cargo en el banco
grameen el banco que el propio yunus
había fundado por supuesto que muchas de
las acusaciones que lanzó contra este
banquero eran ciertas
de hecho mohamed yunus tampoco es una
mosquita muerta pero de eso ya
hablaremos en otro vídeo lo cierto es
que si destituirle de su cargo no era
suficiente hasina emprendió una campaña
para desprestigiarle
fascina asegura que el premio nobel
yunus consiguió que hillary clinton
detenga los fondos del banco mundial
para el puente de batman en otras
palabras que sheikh hasina sabe cómo
derrotar a sus enemigos políticos
primero era yunus ahora es la banca
islámica
[Música]
así que la pregunta es de verdad hay una
conexión entre la banca islámica y el
terrorismo o se trata simplemente de una
excusa del gobierno de bangladesh para
poder tener las finanzas bajo control
debería bangladesh permitir que la banca
islámica siga desarrollando su actividad
con total normalidad podeis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
mientras tanto si queréis saber más
sobre esta parte del mundo en este otro
vídeo os hablamos del conflicto en el
himalaya entre china y la india haced
click aquí para verlo y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]